hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's sister location now there's a
few things that I want to talk about
before we get started number one these
security cameras here who's watching
those cameras because in the last one
when I edited the video baby and her
crew said she's watching us not he's
watching us she's watching us so who is
that is that the voice on the intercom
is the voice on the intercom actually
baby and there's baby those little
voices in there just the babies in there
so there's a lot of mysteries here also
this this yes and this last one doesn't
do anything and neither does that so
anyway that's a whole bunch of stuff not
important right now we're gonna get back
to Freddy's little room here and ready
baby
first we gotta get the rib Laura Dannon
nnnnnn Laura no no no no no no no none
kill me no no no no no none
speaking make it oh yeah
suck on that okay so I'm pretty sure my
transfer breathing room
you may now interface with the breaker
control box okay using the interface may
disrupt nearby electronics if you feel
you are in danger feel free to
disconnect the interface temporarily
until it is safe to reconnect uh-huh
okay so I think my problem here was I
tried to do too many at once like
obviously the danger is going to be bad
[Music]
hi hi oh okay he moves I dunno he moved
is it is it really okay I don't know my
bad
so just save a little bit of progress
but I can listen for the shuffling shoe
of a of a wild bear oh geez oh yeah go
back to sleep oh god hi how are you
doing oh go go oh and no one's here oh
my god that smile that that winning
smile it's so nice okay that's a shuffle
that's a shoes runner I think I think
the little voice is Bonnie but Bonnie's
talking to fun time Freddy and that's
not a happy do what's happy for go and
who's that voice who's talking about
bond who's talking about but is that
Freddy is that Freddie's voice where's
Freddy sound like such a douche and oh
great job this completes your tasks for
the night please proceed back through
the bowl or a gallery with care and
we'll see you back here tomorrow I could
have done that in the last episode I
didn't know it was gonna end right there
Wow I feel light-headed oh god no oh god
not again
done antenna no no no speaking no no no
no no Laura no no
no go back to sleep
I think who's just the mouse I think
there's a bee your lies yeah that's the
one you need to worry about me I just
need to worry about me and don't mind
the yelling I yell when I'm nervous
[Music]
we did it we're the best in the world
and we are friends for Oh ever okay
anyway I guess my friend song is over oh
good as this myselfs so also does
another chapter in the saga of love lost
between Vlad and his distressed mistress
can they be reconciled and their love
rise again that and more happening now I
know Danna the baby isn't mine it is
Vlad they had trouble catching him in
the nursery today saw what lots of kids
get hyper and run around and stuff they
had to knock him out of the air with a
broom
I have to go they're going to dock your
paychecks they can't do that I'm a
vampire I don't get paychecks you work
the graveyard shift at the fry me taco
don't lie to me
oh the humanity oh and will the
heartbreak in when will these two ships
passing in the night
rekindle their long lost love tune in
tomorrow to find out my god it's so
bizarre
because I am ajan this is trying to
paint this guy's existence as a normal
everyday Joe and he just after he's done
working he goes home
heywood ha she's so pretty and shiny
didn't you make her just for me
okay so what's interesting about back is
that voice I believe is the daughter of
welcome back to another pivotal night of
your thriving new career where you get
to really ask yourself what am I doing
with my life what would my friends say
and most importantly will I ever see my
family again we understand the stresses
of a new job and we're here for you to
help you reach a more stable and
relaxing frame of mind we offer several
musical selections to help make this
elevator ride as relaxing and
therapeutic as possible
we offer contemporary jazz classical
rain forest ambience as well as a wide
selection of other choices using the
keypad below please type the first few
letters of the musical selection you
would prefer sure it seems you had some
trouble with the keypad I see what you
were trying to type and I will
autocorrect it for you up step thank you
for selecting casual bongo cat mr. hook
now that your elevator experience has
been customized to your needs and you're
thoroughly relaxed it's worth mentioning
that due to your lackluster performance
yesterday your pay has been decreased by
a substantial amount please enjoy the
rest of your descent what these casual
bongos have turned sour how can you say
that what did I do
well come on Oh also mr. Ashton
apparently is a character in the book
and apparently that's purple guy whoever
that is is purple guy but then that
would make purple guy the creator of
this these animatronics so what does it
all mean
can we cut the casual bongos huh there's
gonna bond goes that's gonna fall to
unforeseen malfunctions from today's
shows your nightly duties will require
you to perform maintenance that you may
or may not be skilled enough to perform
oh it became necessary for technicians
to attempt to disconnect funtime
Freddy's power module however they were
unsuccessful allowing them to try again
would be an inefficient path forward as
we would need to allow six to eight
weeks for recovery and physical therapy
you will need to reach the parts and
service room on the other side of
funtime auditorium to perform the
procedure yourself let's check on bolero
first and make sure she's on her stage
great it looks like everything is as it
should be in Valora gallery let's check
on funtime foxy it's important to make
sure she's on her stage before a jury ah
ok so this foxy is definitely a female
but you know that's that's a revelation
that's gonna have to go in second place
- what the [ __ ] I just saw over on
velour stage huh ok ever you know never
mind maybe I shouldn't be so
oh yeah Fox great it looks like
everything is as it should be in funtime
auditorium there is no need to check on
baby tonight please refrain from
entering unauthorized areas proceed
directly to funtime auditorium I excuse
me are you trying to tell me what to do
how dare you I'm gonna go straight into
baby's room and check on baby cuz if
there's one thing that mark a bar is
it's a good daddy and I'm gonna check on
baby
okay so what have we got up here alright
oh boy I don't think I should be here
I'm pretty sure I shouldn't be here
there any reason for this do I need to
be here boy hmm did you know that I was
on stage once it wasn't for very long
only one day what a wonderful day though
I was in a small room with balloons and
a few tables no one sat at the tables
though but children would run in and out
some were afraid of me others enjoyed my
songs music was always coming from
somewhere else down a hall
I would always count the children I'm
not sure why I was always acutely aware
of how many there were in the room with
me two then three then two and three and
four
then two then none they usually played
together in groups of two or three
I was covered in glitter I smelled like
birthday cake there were two then three
then five then four I can do something
special did you know that I can make ice
cream although I only did it once
there were four then three then two then
one something happened when there was
one a little girl standing by herself I
was no longer myself and I stopped
singing my stomach opened and there was
ice cream
I couldn't move at least not until she
sucked closer they were screaming for a
moment but only for a moment
then other children rushed in again but
they couldn't hear her over the sounds
of their own excitement I still hear her
sometimes why did that happen
ah that painted a very vivid picture of
something exceptionally [ __ ]
let me tried to rationalize exactly what
she was talking about there she uh she
was onstage once with balloons and such
not some sort of birthday party
establishment and then there was one
girl in the room and it's entirely
possible it's entirely possible that
that one girl was the daughter of mr.
Ashton who is the purple guy up
supposedly and the purple guy made this
animatronic in her his daughter's image
and then it made ice cream out of her or
maybe not I don't know
oh that's horrifying oh that's so
horrifying but that would make sense
unless her counting thing was only
looking for an opportunity for there to
be one person in the room and then oh
man either way who I am NOT glad I came
in here I regret that very much so so
let's skedaddle on out here and continue
on to funtime foxy because hopefully
circus scary holy [ __ ] ah that's
interesting though because that's the
first time I've ever encountered like a
deliberate easter egg in this game
everything else has been random chance
but that's the first time you could like
incidentally go to something and reveal
more of the story so let's carry on to
funtime foxy and recap Tori maintenance
vent opened unlikable aura
funtime foxy is motion activated for
this reason it's important to keep the
room dark as to not accidentally
activate her you have been provided with
a flash beacon use it if you need to get
your bearings and to ensure you don't
bump into anything however use it as
sparingly as possible proceed forward to
reach the parts and service room
okay a boof the [ __ ] I didn't see
anything the truth
oh boy
[Music]
okay oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh
god cupcakes oh hi oh oh this seems uh
this seems not so good huh I I'm not
really sure I understand exactly what's
going on here but something tells me
it's not it's not entirely good oh it's
a shotgun cupcake ah alright you want
you want a cupcake kid I'll get both you
what okay
oh yeah you all enjoy your cupcakes yeah
what is happening here what is going on
no idea grow one kid
oh man I'm out of cups oh man I'm out of
cakes oh geez Oh green one all that
that's
good what does this do do I even want to
know
oh it carries through goddammit I wish I
knew what these things did before I used
them dang it
oh dang it Oh dagnabbit well we're just
gonna have one kid without it
so that's nice I don't I don't have any
I don't have any you guys are all
screwed I'm literally out how do you
expect me to do anything
oh boy whoa whoa whoa whoa gran okay you
guys are just gonna do without what can
I do
[Music]
hell yeah I made it
Oh game over I forgot that I died well
alright then so that's a thing okay you
have been provided with a flash because
I got boned so uh don't just walk
forward in the dark is the the name of
the game there okay so when I hear a
movement in the darkness I think that's
foxy moving around so I'm gonna wait
until I hear like a sound that signifies
like
in front of me
oh geez I don't know
[Music]
I thought I had that I thought that was
a distinct sound when she moves in front
of you and then a distinct sound when
she moves away whoo boy oh boy yeah I'm
just gonna take my time on this one I'm
gonna wait good long time between each
movement seems to be working it just is
taking a long time my theory is that
there's a reason they have the sound the
recharging so it acts like as a it acts
like as a timer for how long it takes to
cool down
foxy so hopefully that's a better way of
going about it but I don't know for sure
but it seems to be working parts and
surveys great job reaching parts and
service it seems that fun time Freddy is
out of power which should make your job
much easier the release switch for the
chest cavity is located on the underside
of the endoskeleton jaw to reach it we
will first need to open the faceplates
you will need to press the faceplate
release triggers in a specific order and
it's important to be as precise and as
careful as possible locate the small
button on Freddy's face just under his
right cheek and press it oh okay
great now locate the button under his
left cheek and passion no I did the
right cheek I did his right okay oh
great now carefully locate and press the
button next to Freddie's right eye this
one great now carefully locate and press
the button just above Freddy's nose okay
good job your faceplates should now be
open locate and press the small button
on the underside of Freddie's
endoskeleton jaw excellent the chest
cavity should now be open remove the
power module from the chest cavity
oh god this why is he over here great
work you will now be required to remove
the secondary power module from the
bonnie hand puppet press the large black
button beneath Bonnie's bowtie to
release the power module hey hey hey
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh how do i how do I do this
what
I don't like that how in the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do this hmm
am I supposed to I I thought it was
under the jar is it his nose I'm
supposed to boob am I supposed to boob
his nose that's the large black button
beneath Bonnie's bowtie to release the
power module ah I would I just he won't
show it to me dude okay I see him
oh he's slowly rising okay he's slowly
rising if I can just catch him enough ah
boink
I got I got that oh I so got that god
damn it okay so we've Ryze he's gonna
rise rise a little more no more no more
no more I got you I got you I got you
ah yeah great job you've acquired both
power modules this completes your tasks
for the night yeah please exit the
building through fun time auditorium and
we'll see you back here again tomorrow
Rick how am I gonna be able to get back
holy [ __ ] oh boy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
Foxy's not gonna talk to me like B Laura
did it's gonna be me versus him and
that's fine it's totally okay so you can
run in between but you have to wait the
long periods of time for him to really
cool down and then flash make sure it's
clear and then gun it the only thing you
can do cuz otherwise if you run just in
the dark you're gonna die but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna test my theory
indefinitely I'm gonna wait very
patiently to make sure that I do not die
cuz I don't want to do all that again
Rick [ __ ] you god damn it [ __ ] up daddy
she can make balloons have you seen her
make balloons Oh
dad let me go to her what what what what
she be still that quiet why you've been
sleeping for quite a while hey I think
they noticed that you never left the
building last night
the cameras were searching for you but
they couldn't find you
I have you hidden - well I kidnapped you
Oh what's a fairy I'm not going to hurt
you
uh-huh yeah sure okay I'm only going to
keep you for a little while why try not
to make although you're inside something
that came from my old pizzeria I don't
think it was ever used at least not the
way it was meant to be used yes too
dangerous it's just big enough for one
person to fit inside but just barely
Oh am I in like one of those in the
scooping room do you know why they call
it a scooping room right it's because
dummy this is the room where they use a
scooper I thought that would be obvious
well gee isn't that a fun name for
something Hey the scooper maybe it
sounds like something you would use for
ice cream or custard or sprinkles it
sounds like something you would want it
your birthday party
to ensure that you get a heaping portion
of every good and thing I wonder though
if you were a freshly opened kind of
ice-cream how you would feel about
something with that name thankfully I
don't think of freshly opened mind of
ice cream feels anything at all oh it
sounds like someone else is in the
building she okay bring a roller forward
one okay stop
set it down watch the step what happened
to it this time just seems like these
things can't go a day break it down it's
always the same man hardware malfunction
well I gotta be somewhere
15 minutes in this place gives me the
creeps we just get this over with
to all and let me forward just get home
roll
[Music]
Oh
oh okay yeah there's something very
important that I've learned how to do
over time do you know what that is no
your daddy to pretend do you ever play
make-believe they pretend to be one way
when you are really the other it's very
important but Laura never learns but I
do they think there is something wrong
on the inside the only thing that
matters is knowing how to pray I'll open
the faceplates for you anyway that way
they can find you on the cameras I don't
want it now all you have to do is wait
I'd recommend that you keep the
spring-locks wound up your breathing and
your heartbeat are causing them to come
loose you don't want them to get too
loose oh just okay okay how do i okay i
just got clicking hold on him why is
below her looking at me whines below her
looking at me why did I we'll chill
dammit
oh hi who the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ]
are you I'll look at you in just a
second the holy [ __ ]
what is that what was that do I do I
don't know okay that's all the time I
have for this episode here wow this is
just wild like everything that I knew is
thrown out the window and it's all new
stuff which is good and it kind of ties
together with something that I realized
that you know when Scott first announced
this game and released the first trailer
it didn't even have five nights at
Freddy's in the name if you look back on
the trailer on YouTube it just says
sister location trailer one and I think
there's a point to that were not at
Freddy fazbear's pizzaria were just not
like that's not why we're here this is a
whole new experience so I'm gonna
continue this in another episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]